c'est à paris au ministère d outre mer
que se sont tenues les dernières
rencontres étudiante sous l'impulsion de
l'europe
des agents de la direction de
l'éducation du département de la réunion
rencontre de jeunes étudiants
réunionnais ils ont tous un point commun
ils bénéficient du dispositif net bourse
des aides départementales aux études
supérieures
ça nous permet de recueillir au bout de
trois mois d'installation les
je vis de ces étudiants shenzhen les
façons de l'est
initiée de les débloquer les problèmes
qu'ils rencontrent également de leur vie
quotidienne tant au plan universitaire
de vous des conditions d'hébergement
partager des expériences améliorer les
dispositifs d aide ces rencontres sur le
terrain vise à répondre au mieux aux
besoins de ses étudiants et je pense que
c'est toujours bien de partager votre
expérience j'aurais aimé qu'on me dit
c'est même chose
allons je pars parce que vous savoir et
pouvoir prendre les décisions tout
pleine connaissance de cause
le bus aurait pas qu'il y avait ce genre
dette
si on est au courant pas automatiquement
ça nous pousse vers l'avant on est plus
ambitieux du coup je trouve ça vraiment
bien parce que moi effectivement dans ma
promo il ya des élèves qui viennent de
tous horizons et ils ont pas forcément
les mêmes aides que nous et moi c'est
une chance et le dispositif net beauce
propose trois types dead une bourse
départementale la location de scolarité
et la mise à disposition de logements à
la cité internationale universitaire de
paris 85 logements sont ainsi réservés à
des étudiants réunionnais de niveau bac
+4 minimum
larissa dahra fille occupe un de ses
studios à la cité universitaire de paris
bon bah alesi venez voilà mon studio que
j'ai eu avec l'aide du département
c'est à la soupe dix neuvième porte des
lilas c1 18 mètres carrés mais je me
sens bien
pour ma dernière année d'études étudiant
en 5e année d'école de commerce sur le
campus de paris
larissa dahra fille à bénéficier des
aides du dispositif net bourse
un accompagnement du département qui
pousse les jeunes réunionnais vers les
filières d'excellence sans la du
département je partais en 3ème année
universitaire à saint denis et à l'île
de la réunion et la grâce à cette aide
j'ai pu j'ai pu continuer mes études
par ma 3e 4e et 5e années je viens d'une
famille modeste
malheureusement quand j'avais demandé
aux banques de me prêter de le prêter de
l'argent
on m'avait on avait refusé à cause du
revenu modeste de ma mère est
jeudi que les réunionnais ont une chance
d'avoir ce dispositif puisque nos amis
les antilles plus de dix mille étudiants
bénéficient chaque année des aides de
n'être bourse
cofinancé par le département de la
réunion et l'union européenne
ces fonds porte la jeunesse réunionnaise
vers les études supérieures et les
grandes écoles
les demandes de subventions se font via
le portail net bourse
un dispositif qui fonctionne grâce à
tout un service et une équipe d'agents
du département dédié à cette mission
d'accompagnement